zemmour c'est assez simple c'est
quelqu'un qui vous dit l'identité
française est en cause les français sont
divisés
et qui propose comme solution
l'accentuation de la fragmentation et
l'accentuation de la division puisque si
vous regardez ce qu'il dit
fondamentalement c'est qu'il y a
plusieurs millions de françaises et de
français ou en tout cas de jean
séjournant sur notre sol mais beaucoup
ayant la nationalité française qui ne
devraient pas y être pour cause de
religion parce qu'ils pratiquent une
religion l'islam qu'eric zemmour
considère comme incompatible avec la
république française
la solution qu'il préconise devrait donc
être l'expulsion de 6 millions de
français ou la conversion forcée or on
n'a pas procéder à des conversions
forcées en matière religion depuis louis
xiv et la répression des protestants il
est évident que son projet est une
impasse pétales et que donc si par
malheur il était élu il y aurait dans un
premier temps une très très grande
crispation et dans un second temps une
très très grande déception